[Music]
the feeling of Corbett Illig are only
the oligarchs have it easy here in
Russia everyone else gays teachers
journalists people with HIV have it
tough with you as a gay man I feel
social pressure each and every day
homophobia has become trendy you can
even earn money with it make a name for
yourself homophobes get invited on to
primetime TV chat shows and make even
more magnificent will she doing
while naka de la pêche la pelea Batista
current campaign of homophobia got going
back in 2013 when the law banning
so-called gay propaganda was passed and
people thought it wouldn't change much
but now we're really feeling the impact
I look off me
sodomites pervert [ __ ] out of our city
we don't need immigrants and we don't
need gays what we need is a healthy
society the church home and children
those are the values we need in your
mind but the most though we learn of is
here to distract people he's a colorful
character
he fits the bill it's about distracting
people from the real social and economic
problems that exist problems that really
affect our future
he says gays are Western agents to
undermine Russia's moral foundations
from the inside out now that was really
good Disney Koala when the first report
is about the persecution of gays in
Chechnya came in I reacted you incent
Petersburg there's a breach named after
the Chechen president's father I
handcuffed myself to it
to me one of her a twin use of the stunt
spread malone of said i should scrub the
bridge with detergent to get rid of what
he called the AIDS contamination I'd
left behind the thing is that I actually
am HIV positive of what but how could he
have known that Missy divisions he
exists how did you know you shouldn't
cancel the nuclei pollution that was
difficult to hear it's exactly the
pressure I was talking about you realize
that the whole government machine is
against you stuff that I put in a
promotion it doesn't matter if it's
Putin who's in charge or someone else no
one's ever going to get rid of the
discriminatory laws we have
[Music]
nathaniell cumulus here but all the same
I like Russia I don't want to go
anywhere else I want to do everything I
can to live a free life yes for multiple
inlets
you